my name's Daniel near Bayou minute and
our film is texting and the website is
text me film com it was behind text me
where did you begin the story process
what inspired it's all about the texting
generation and now there's not as much
human communication it's all about
texting and facebooking and our films
facebook yes my headspace and facebook
mixed together so it's kind of fun but
yeah we just wanted to comment on the
texting generation like the whole you
know communication in our modern digital
era so we hooked up with a really
talented kid you know teenager who we
want to represent the teenage generation
since his kid Matt Bennett who's in that
shoe victorious on nickelodeon he's also
in the new movie will ferrell's
virginity hit and we just collaborated
the team and we came up with his
moodiness 12 best comedy awards and you
know nominated by fox and fox
searchlight drink works and we've done
really well with it tesco festival and
so far i like probably sure this fun
Thank You secure funding for the film
how did you raise my life orally well
you know what is 10 be used to doing
projects like we do project a project or
projects so we just know how to pull it
off for little money and we sort of got
our friends together and just wanted to
make a film and we just you know pay for
ourselves now we got a distribution deal
and you know some people are shown to
buy the DVD so we're getting money back
and we won surprises believe that you'll
recoup your investment or or or me it's
not really about that you know for me
making a short film is just a way to get
into a larger world so because of this
home we were able to get producers
interested in making a feature so we're
going to start in late August on our
pre-production for our future film
now we're getting the word out about
your project right now we live in New
York like I said before we reached out
to the neighborhood that we lived it and
we shot it in and so we got all kinds
like four or five different interviews
and then we're also in a different film
festival i don't know if i should
mention that but they're going to
they're going to feature our film and
have it in time square so for a very
executives yeah
as many people we can talk to and get
the film out there and like I said we've
been in different film festival so
that's been really fun for us to all
over the states even Canada we got
written up in like five different
newspapers very in the last week and it
like just as a team because we're
husband and wife co-director co-writer
team like to dream team so thanks they
like that it's like a cool you know
something they don't see that often most
successful team
Oh